hey dr. Berg here I want to invite you
to a special presentation I'm doing
called beyond weight loss advanced
strategies for stubborn belly fat this
seminar is for that individual that has
tried everything and nothing is working
the person that has a lot of failures in
the area of weight loss even if they eat
healthy okay we're talking about why 90%
of all weight loss programs fail that is
a terrible percentage we're going to
show you why that is we're going to
about hormone balancing and why that's
not a good idea if you want to lose
weight and that will surprise you and
then the biggest thing that destroys the
adrenal gland 3 NAL's are the stress
Glen top of the kidney that's the thing
that causes belly fat and then how to
lower cortisol that's the stress hormone
that not only makes belly fat but it
destroys the rest of your body too I'm
going to cover some new things that you
probably have never heard before and
then we'll we'll talk about what all
successful diets have in common so then
you don't have to reinvent the wheel
we're going to show you what works what
doesn't work you can take a lot of notes
so register today
and I will see you on the inside